travel everyone's favorite loose lip
Prince Harry may have found himself in
hot water yet again but this time for
being too honest the Duke of Sussex
facing yet more questions over how he
got his U.S visa approved after
admitting to taking a variety of drugs
in his autobiography spare Piers
Morgan's favorite bedtime read the Duke
of Sussex revealing of course in this
book that he tried cocaine smoked
marijuana and experimented with magic
mushrooms here's a snippet from that
audiobook
psychedelics did me some good as well
I'd experimented with them over the
years for fun but now I'd begun to use
them therapeutically of course I had
been doing cocaine around this time
at someone's Country House during a
shooting weekend I've been offered a
line and I'd done a few more since
there you go literally in black and
white talking about his drug use now
conservative think
to Heritage Foundation is appealing a
U.S court to unseal Prince Harry's
immigration records in the hope that he
may get kicked out of the country as a
result I'm now joined to discuss this by
author and cultural commentator Bonnie
Greer always so good on U.S issues and
Prince Harry former head of Royal
protection dye Davis also joining us di
will be out to you shortly but first
let's head over to Nile Gardner whose
organization is the one the Heritage
Foundation appealing to unseal Prince
Harry's immigration records now let's
just start simply what's your motivation
for doing this
well thanks for having me on the show
today and uh basically we are calling
for accountability and transparency on
the part of the the by Administration we
believe there is a clear public interest
in the release of Prince Harry's
immigration records especially uh in
light of the extensive Revelations of
illegal drug use uh in spur and we want
to ensure of course that Prince Harry
was honest and fully transparent in his
immigration application to the United
States we also want to ensure that there
is no preferential treatment given
towards a Prince Harry everyone should
be treated equally by by the law and the
Heritage Foundation believes strongly in
the robust application of immigration
law we have been the leading voice I'd
say in the United States in many decades
in support of strong uh application of
U.S immigration laws and we are the view
that Prince Harry should not be in any
way treated differently to anybody else
applying to the United States I'm
remember the royal family you seem to
think that he got preferential treatment
by the Biden Administration
um and there might be some evidence in
these unsealed documents that prove that
but I just I'm interested in your
motivations as a British person over in
the US doing this to another Brit
well British Crossing but I have U.S
citizenship as well uh and uh you know
my my motivation here is to ensure that
immigration laws applied by U.S
authorities that that's the motivation
here Prince Harry of course has become a
huge public figure in the United States
uh he is a a big figure on both sides to
the Atlantic he's a household name uh in
America there is intense public interest
actually in this uh upcoming uh court
hearing uh and opinion polls have shown
produced by Newsweek for example that a
majority of Americans want to see the
release of Prince Harry's immigration
record so this has been very closely
followed by millions of Americans uh and
uh it's our view that no one should be
should be uh treated uh in a
preferential away here the law should be
applied equally to everybody regardless
of celebrity status or or membership of
the royal family uh and Prince Harry
should be treated no different
especially in light of the extensive
drug use Revelations that he made
himself yeah no doubt there are
extensive drug use Revelations let's
speak to another American citizen here
in the studio in London
and everything else in between and of
course you don't speak on behalf of all
Americans you have your own views but
what's your reaction to Nile well that's
very fascinating to hear now actually
describe a proxy war between the
Heritage Foundation and the Bible
Administration with for all Harry as the
hostage it's going to be really really
interesting uh to watch this uh roll out
uh the Heritage Foundation has become if
I can use the term more Maga since uh
the Trump Administration they are the
number one conservative thing tank they
built the Reagan Administration and now
they become all Maga and now they've got
Paul Harry and their site as a way to
fight actually the Homeland Security
Department uh because parts of the
Republican Party want to impeach the
head of the home of Homeland Security so
Harry's in the middle of all of this and
I think and you know as far as now
saying that all America wants to know
his drug records really so
um
I hopefully for Harry's sake that
everything is sort of lined up as it
should be but I support the deal the
Department of Homeland Security's
refusal to unseal the records because
they don't do that this is always at the
discretion of the immigration department
immigration officer and so it's going to
be an interesting battle we'll come back
to now to get his response to uh your
suggestions there uh of how this is all
being used but let's come out to diet
because you're a former head of Royal
protection and let's just talk about if
if Harry uh you know the drug use is
there and if he does loot his U.S sort
of residency right should he come back
to the UK
well it's an interesting dilemma whether
he wants to come back I don't know I
suspect he doesn't uh given all the fura
that's going on and of course he's in
court himself next week which will be a
very interesting scenario to see him
actually in the witness box one of the
first Royals other than his great great
uh grandfather actually going into a
witness box so it'll be very interesting
my perspective is is that he's a
household name both here and America and
if he admits to taking cocaine and Other
Drugs he's at the end of a criminal
organization who Thrive unfortunately on
those who want to take drugs in this
country and indeed in America it's an
epidemic so for him to come out in my
view foolishly to actually articulate
the fact that he's been taking it not
once but not twice but on a regular
basis I think is extremely foolish and
again I I wondered who counseled him
that was a sensible thing to do
it does seem diet that there is a bit of
a lack of counsel there look I'm really
sorry we aren't just so so close out of
time I want to give Nile just
opportunity to say is what Bonnie's
saying true about your motivations
well it was quite great to listen to
Bonnie and I but I have to disagree with
with Bonnie's comments that you know
Prince Harry is not some sort of uh
hostage here
um you know Prince Harry is is a huge
public figure in his in his own right uh
I think there's a clear public interest
here
um and uh and I I do think that uh as
well the buying Administration uh needs
to operate in a transparent constructive
manner If Prince Harry has nothing to
hide here he should fully support the
release of his own records
many many immigration records have been
released in fact Kamala Harris's
mother's immigration records were
released so many uh individuals well we
will see if the Biden Administration do
play ball I'm really sorry to cut you
off we are fresh out of time uh thanks
so much for all three of you for giving
your views to see